avec noomi homsy économistes et pdg de
l'institut du québec mont soir madame
own site pourquoi alors on voit
aujourd'hui le taux de chômage qui
diminue mais moins rapidement que dans
les mois précédents quand même qu est ce
que ça nous dit sur le marché de
l'emploi
bertrand ou peuvent tout étonné les
jupons aujourd'hui et on se rappellera
qu'au début le québec quand un
confinement qui étaient plus rapides
plus agressif que l'ampleur dans le
province et on a aussi des confiné plus
rapidement donc les bénéfices de ce
déconfinement hafid on les a vus au
cours des derniers mois ya pas beaucoup
de choses qui ont changé et dans les
règles
au cours des derniers mois donc c'est
normal que lille la récupération soit
plus lente mais quand même vu pour un
site pourtant c'est pas mauvais 1h 17 %
taux de chômage au début de la crise
donc c'est quand même encourageant même
si ça ralentit et en russe points
importants ce mois ci leur retrait
quatre ans après alors qu'elle
moderniste du temps partiel et c'est
surtout le secteur
l'idée donc cdh estime d'une certaine
vigueur marche travail qui relie donc
c'est encourageant mais c'est pas tout
qui est encourageant au regard des
heures travaillées par exemple qui sont
en baisse ça veut dire qu'il ya des gens
qui aimeraient travailler plus mais qui
ont peu de quarts de travail c'est la
même chose pour les travailleurs
autonomes
oui c'est ce qu'on voit aussi dans les
délits ont commencé dans un ami couteau
d'activité revenez donc les personnes
qui avaient décidé
probablement parce que les enfants pour
plusieurs raisons
peut-être la pcu les multiples
hypothèses mais qui avait dû se retirer
du marché du travail au cours des
derniers mois reviennent dans la
population active parce qu'on voit
quelque chose d'acoustique presque
revenue au niveau d'avant la crise donc
les gens réclament ans à chercher du
travail mais c'est encore difficile et
on voit aussi le phénomène par tous cas
mandat que les heures travaillées sont
en baisse de façon assez prononcé donc
peut-être que les emplois maintenant
autres moins d'heures de travail dont
peut-être que les gens aimeraient
travailler davantage
je vous dirais qu'avec la fin de la
piste et l'on va voir beaucoup de ce qui
est dû aux mesures gouvernementales et
ce qui est dû à la crise des secteurs et
à la santé économique ou si de l'eau
secteur parce qu'il faut pas se faire
d'illusions elle l'économie ne
retrouvera pas la meilleure qu'elle
avait compté very ou l'an dernier du
jour au lendemain il va y avoir des
séquelles va avoir des entreprises qui
ne pourront pas se relever on voit pas
lorsque les jt oui parce que j'entends
comme on dit c'est que l'amélioration
sur le marché de l'emploi qu'on a vu
très rapide depuis le printemps
ce sera beaucoup plus lent à l'automne
encore qu'est ce qui nous attend dans
les prochains mois mersen dans les
prochains mois
comment savoir un sevrage serveurs et
des mesures d instinct des mesures
gouvernementales de soutien à l'emploi
qui était très costaud ça va commencer à
rester surtout la paix sic enfin en
septembre donc l'ombre on va voir
vraiment et ils mesurent aux entreprises
on va voir quelle entreprise ont été
capables de survivre
il est qu'elles vont tomber au combat
donc au courant des prochains mois voire
un peu plus ce livre est sympa de la
crise sur l'économie réelle et donc sur
la santé du marché du travail
on ne peut tout lui encore long
mais quand même au début la vallée le
bilan d'aujourd'hui on observe on
souligne entre autres chez statistique
canada une différence importante pour le
taux de chômage en général le taux de
chômage des minorités aussi le ce sont
des données canadiennes qu'on a à
l'écran presque 18% le taux de chômage
pour les canadiens d'origine arabe 17,6
pour cent pour les canadiens noirs pour
ceux qui sont d'origine asiatique l'asie
du sud-est 5,6 pour cent
un écart comme c'est ce que ça vous
étonne mais ce sont des nouvelles de lui
avec statistique canada publie donc on
peut pas vraiment comparer avec la
situation qui prévalait avant mais quand
on regarde quand même la situation des
immigrants on voit ça fait partie des
gros qui sont les plus touchés comme
d'ailleurs les femmes les plus jeunes et
les travailleurs à bas salaires donc on
voit que quand je connais niveau moyen
par une récession
tout le monde n'est pas touchées de la
même façon et surtout les records et de
l'aï majeur sur la reprise dont don que
genre groupon qui frappe fortement début
de la crise mais la reprise favorise
surtout les hommes et surtout des gens
qui le composent 2009-10 et de
l'immigration
bon comment on fait maintenant là pour
accélérer le pas bon il ya le marché de
l'emploi mais l économie aussi qu'est ce
qu'on doit faire pour accélérer cette
reprise à l'automne
mais en fait ce qu'on voit c'est que des
secteurs sont touchés l'autre c'est
évident que les secteurs que les arts la
culture le tourisme l'hôtellerie l'est
a sion le commerce sont plus touchées
alors que d'autres secteurs où il y
avait des jeux des enjeux majeurs des
pénuries de main d'oeuvre comme la santé
les technologies de l'information
l'éducation mais on voit que c'est
encore plus criant dans votre va leur
trouver une façon d'aider les gens dans
les secteurs touchés à se former de se
qualifier pour retrouver un emploi tu
veux les intéressés mais l'on était
besoin et non on est vraiment un village
de l'économie a refermé sur virage qui
vaut ici avec ou est-ce qu'on veut que
le québec soit dans dix quinze ans c'est
quoi les secteurs pourraient encourager
dont fois investir la peinture que le
virage numérique par exemple mais aussi
investir dans la formation des
formations soit plus rapide plus juste
plus agile plus flexible qu'on finance
les gens comme on le fait avec les prix
pozo belissaoui fer avec le gouvernement
c'est la panique à réagir rapidement de
façon efficace avec des mesures assez
audacieux le payer par les gens pendant
la formation
mais peut-être dans ce secteur on veut
devant bon ce sont des questions qui
vont vous occuper encore beaucoup
pendant les prochaines semaines les
prochains mois vous avez entre autres
été nommé pdg de l'institut du québec
cette semaine
est-ce que vous avez un objectif si vous
en aviez un à nous donner pour votre
nouveau mandat ce serait quoi mais c'est
sûr qu'avec tout ce qui se passe dans un
contexte actuel c'est hyper moins de 26
noms de certaines passant pour eux les
économies surtout dans un teint on doit
bien pousser des politiques publiques
qui vont errer aux gens vont pouvoir
aider les gens se replacer dans
l'économie non on veut vraiment
posez les questions d'emploi de finances
publiques ou site parce que ça va tous
nous toucher de très près très
rapidement
qui va payer pour tout ça et surtout le
faire en collaboration avec d'autres
personnes et avec une grande ouverture
d'esprit et on va suivre le fruit de vos
travaux évidemment à l'automne merci
beaucoup merci merci